à plus de 70 ans la dame de fer c'est
pour 9,7 à l'abri des regards dans un
entrepôt de la sncf que cette locomotive
des années 40 a pu renaître de ses
cendres
et pour ce faire il a fallu de
nombreuses heures de travail mais
surtout ce qu'on redoute une clé 245 mm
pour desserrer de gros écrou grosse
machine aux outils une clé à pipe
voilà un peu plus petits pour les écrous
65 mm créé la cedh une plaie quand sert
vraiment à la main fabriquée à l'origine
aux états unis cette locomotive avait
été livré à la france après la guerre
pour remplacer le parc ferroviaire de la
sncf détruits par les bombardements
aujourd'hui les bénévoles de l'amicale
des cheminots tente de préserver ce
patrimoine historique une réelle chance
pour ces passionnés du rail qui
manipulent rarement ce genre de pièces
anciennes ya déjà le fait de toucher les
pièces où on sait qu'elles sont
anciennes
on sait que les premières qui ont été
faites comme celle qu'on touche peuvent
dater de 1920 mais c'est toujours les
mêmes et on s'aperçoit que nos anciens
faisait simple à l'oeil
une fois à l'intérieur la magie opère
toujours
vannes manomètres sisley le temps semble
s'être arrêté dans cette cabine
michel se prendrait presque au jeu on
est dans le poste de pilotage de la loco
vapeur
donc ce côté si on a le chauffeur celui
qui chauffe et de l'autre côté le
mécanicien celui qui conduit
voilà la porte d'entrée du foyer on
rentre dedans par ici on rentre à 10 là
dedans à dix et même plus après cinq
années de mise aux normes
la locomotive va enfin pouvoir
transporter des voyageurs rendez vous le
16 septembre pour son premier petit tour
de train